le commentaire pour commentaire d'accord
[Musique]
difficile de connaître le sentiment des
salariés
aujourd'hui tout semblait normal et les
rares qui accepte de nous parler non pas
vraiment d'inquiétude pour mon avis deux
infos à l'intérieur il n'y a pas de
problème on n'a pas de souci à voir tout
va bien pour nous en tout cas on n'est
pas inquiet apparemment il n'y a pas de
menaces il faut être plus compétitif
c'est tout le monde mais sinon non là
après on n'en sait pas plus lusine pneu
laurent emploie 450 salariés
cette filiale de michelin est spécialisé
dans le rechapage de pneus pour poids
lourds
selon un diagnostic récent des coûts de
production serait trop élevé pour son
directeur le site n'est pourtant pas sur
la sellette
mais face à la concurrence asiatique pas
le choix il faudra très vite être plus
performant nous avons aujourd'hui des
objectifs de progrès de compétitivité
qui sont atteignables qui sont
atteignables dans les prochaines années
en mobilisant l'ensemble du personnel
des efforts pourraient être demandés aux
salariés et le maire d'avolon lui veut
tout mettre en oeuvre pour sauver les
emplois à long terme il faut que la
région
il est implanté
ça mérite d'être aidé il fait partie des
entreprises vertueuses cycle des polos
me circulaire c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut au projet je rappelle que le site
damas où c'est le dernier présent à
avallon depuis 1950 deux pneus laurent
est le deuxième employeur du bassin aval
au nez dans les années 2000
le site a compté jusqu'à 800 salariés